[Musique]
deux bras et deux mois
qu'est ce qu'on a fait
one was lg corriger ton évaluation et je
pense que tu es capable de faire mieux
j'espère qu'il fera mieux la prochaine
fois à faire mieux la prochaine fois si
tu as un problème vient me voir
la prochaine fois il faudra faire
beaucoup mieux et arrête de dessiner
[Musique]
al adha
mais deux seulement
je ne veux pas qu'on ait dû faire des
longueurs des aspects de notre autorité
[Musique]
les fournit au gouvernement
ce tacle hall est de la troisième
semaine obligations nous exclut dans
trois jours durant trois jours de ce
milieu
bonsoir tout le jour dès lé coach
phocéen a tous envie d'être parent et
même tout de même aux classiques latins
chinois avaient communiqué des jeunes
mamans cours du baril monte et que sa
mère dément des bouquins déplorant un de
moins que les deux milliards de barils à
la guerre est annoncé chez nos voisins
c'est alors un aspect on 07 3 me au
bowling
voilà besoin
et c'est à côté
où va la télé
ça va baigner sans l'eau de là dessus
et de toute façon mis en fout moi est
fatigué voûté monde
sa pt
mais ça dans la forêt
dans mon goûter coq à l'âne elle
et nous ça va chez mamie jacques
vous mangerez chauffer
baladés
d
mais aussi grâce à péter
nissan à la forêt
dans mon goût des quotas
[Musique]
loïc rémy ça va chez marie jacquet
nouveau moi j'ai chauffé
kobaladzé
la dea
[Musique]
vous savez
c'est quoi ce petit lundi
c'est tant mieux
l'imam a les dents
que ni même mois
si vous voulez tout ça
s'il veut pas
non
on vient
et
[Musique]
sur ces machines pour les déchets de
payer 8 5 continents ces écoutes noc la
queue que des déchets ou alors c'est
pour ça que nous on a fait cette machine
pour récupérer les déchets pour que la
pollution y arrête
et usa
[Musique]
en
où
[Musique]
oh
en
je suis inventorie les pièces combat
[Musique]
j'ai tant de choses dans ma vie que j'ai
puis et
et oui
je
toujours
[Musique]
à
ici
amis
niger
mais
les truies
je
oui
[Musique]
paradis